hey youtubers is charlie this is going
to be a break down to the doctor who
clipped that played during children in
need biggest thing confirmed Clara Jenna
Coleman and Moffat have made a few
comments recently about what's happening
in the Doctor Who universe and Missy in
general so I'll start with that also new
round of the giveaway starts now all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video real
simple because we're in Doctor Who limbo
in terms of new official content I'm
making a few changes to my video
schedule but I'll explain that after we
talked about the new footage Christmas
and Clara first Jenna Coleman did an
interview recently where she talked a
little bit about what the action of the
episode is going to be in what she's
gonna be doing after dr. gore what her
plans are very important to note she did
not confirm she was leaving in the
Christmas special she just kind of give
a general idea of what her plans were
for after doctor who mostly chillin out
with Robb Stark and going on auditions
she said the Christmas special itself
though is all about dreaming and what's
real and what's not I realized that's a
very opaque explanation but as we saw in
the teaser Nick Frost as father
Christmas or santa however you want to
think about him is asking Clara why she
stopped believing in him as much as
Doctor Who episodes are all about the
doctor and what his adventures are I
feel like this episode might be told
from cars perspective a little bit more
than usual it's like they're trying to
say that in addition to whatever the big
story with the monster is the episode is
about getting Clark to believe in make
believe things that does not mean that
Nick Frost character is not some
advanced dealing and acting his father
Christmas it seems like that is probably
what's really going on but father
Christmas and the doctor share a lot of
the same abilities so it's also about
her believing in the doctor again I
didn't really take away from the finale
that she stopped believing in the doctor
but I think the part of her that really
believed in fantasies died when Danny
pink died it's like that moment in our
childhood when we say Santa is not real
or father Christmas are we want to think
about him that's what happened for Cara
in the finale when Danny pink died I do
like the idea that father Christmas
might be a Time Lord I mean he and the
doctor do share a lot of the same
abilities like when you think about it
isn't the TARDIS just like a giant bag
of gifts maybe not the gifts you wanted
but always the gifts you needed so
here's some background on some of the
scenes that we can use to make some
theories so we see Clara with father
Christmas first and even though the
sleigh is parked at a weird angle their
gifts spilled out all over the place I
don't think it crashed it's implied that
derp has a pre-existing relationship
with father Christmas and there is some
sort of urgent matter that they're both
involved in that requires Clara I don't
think father Christmas is an evil
character like Missy so I don't think
the doctor is trying to save Clara from
imminent demise like he's not rushing in
to save her wall Santa is talking to her
however he does ask car to get her ass
in the TARDIS no questions asked what
does that mean based on the moment
between the doctor and Nick Frost that
final moment I think they need her to
help solve a problem at the North Pole
and there's a ticking clock like time is
running out I may have mentioned it in
my last video but they have confirmed
that the episode is going to take place
at the North Pole and these people
obviously they're all the supporting
cast the place they're at in this new
clip is like the other big location that
they film that might just be where
Clara's staying right now the creature
in the trailer looks kind of like a nice
warrior without its armor part of me
wants to think because of the Father
Christmas Santa think that's going on
the North Pole is going to be like the
mythological place where he lives and
all these people will be like his elves
quote unquote even though there are
actually elves in this scene if you
didn't spot him that's actually dan
starkey right there the guy that plays
tracks it's kind of weird to see him
without the Strax makeup on but it's
possible there's like this Doctor Who
Grinch storyline crossover happening
that would be funny it's just a theory
Ice Warrior is the Grinch trying to ruin
Christmas by killing all of Nick Frost
people in reality I don't think that's
actually Santa's workshop I think it's
more like a research base something much
more practical I do like the idea of a
nice warrior being the proverbial Grinch
but the interesting thing is that based
on Jenna Coleman's interview and why San
is asking her about why she stopped
believing in him it seems like her
belief is a core part of the solution
like her believing in Santa Claus is
somehow part of them solving whatever
the problem is it's like you have this a
story about Clara believing in made-up
things that might totally be real like
father Christmas Robin Hood or the
doctor however you want to think about
that and then there's the bee story the
monster chase with this creature it's
going to take a whole lot more Clips
before we can actually piece together
what the actual plot of the episode
might be the BBC will continue to post
them though between now and the
Christmas special which I will of course
totally do breakdowns for so be sure to
subscribe to get all that stuff the next
big question is is Clara leaving or
not leaving yes Jenna Coleman said that
she's looking forward to just hanging
out and doing nothing and going on
auditions again doing like normal actor
things but it doesn't mean that she's
leaving right away I feel though if all
the major news sources reporting on
doctor who are hinting that she might
leave there's got to be some truth to it
Moffat has definitely confirmed that
he's back for series 9 writing the first
episode right now they probably won't
produce it till after they're done
filming the Sherlock Christmas special
in January which i will also totally be
doing bonus videos for whatever they
start filming Sherlock stuff but just
like Irene Adler bapat totally confirmed
missy is definitely not dead he said
that villains like that never truly die
the two best car theories that I've seen
are one that she's flat-out leaving at
the end of the Christmas special and the
other being that she might do like a
soft transition like the Martha to Donna
transition where she stays on for a few
episodes of series 9 just to kind of
slowly ease into the new companion just
as an update on the giveaway since i'm
not doing a Q&A for this video the
giveaways just gonna stay open till I
post my next Doctor Who video I might
take next week off but it'll just be
open till I post my next Doctor Who
bonus video let me know that when do you
think the Jenna Coleman is going to
leave doctor who and if you could ask
nick frost for anything what would it be
I think I would probably ask him for a
key to the TARDIS so I'm probably gonna
do at least two to three more bonus
videos between now and the week of
Christmas and then during that week I'll
just do a bunch of Doctor Who and
Sherlock lots of Sherlock videos in
January too i'm super excited about that
I know you're all totally bummed that
series 4 is delayed but that Christmas
episode is like a full 90 minute episode
like a regular episode of Sherlock in
the meantime you can click here for my
doctor who finale video and click here
to start getting ready for Sherlock
series 4 thank you so much for watching
so let's all high five I will see you
guys tomorrow
you